we're live
Mr snow
after everything you've seen out there
in the world
what are the Hunger Games for
[Music]
coming
The Hunger Games they're to punish the
districts us tributes don't have a
choice
[Applause]
Your Role is to turn these children into
spectacles not survivors
we're alive
smile it's why we have teeth
I just want to know that somebody still
cared about me that I was still a value
welcome to the Capitol you look like you
shouldn't be here I shouldn't but I'm
your Mentor a rebel
protect people
and it's essential to accept what human
beings are
what it takes to control them
news that faith no child
you seem like a good man Carlina snow I
have seen what war does to people
filled with the turf becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction
engulfing the world
the monsters all of you
good luck with that poor little Songbird
where is she
it's mystery and Mysteries have a way of
driving people
no let me ask you one final time what
are the Hunger Games for
Hanging
Tree
it's the things we love most and destroy
us